inside kaley cuoco 'he's a single girl
home a seer horse inspired makeover I
have horses for years
riding horses for years I love animals
she wasn't joking you guys check out
this pic she shared to Instagram on
Wednesday
it's ermes horse wallpaper plastered
from floor to ceiling in her breakfast
room and at three hundred and forty five
dollars per roll and an estimated ten
rolls it's not cheap the 30 year old
joked in her caption quote I know I know
someone stopped me I can't help it I
love wallpaper Kaylee collab with famed
a decorator Jeff Andrews on her homes
fresh new look and they've been working
on the project for a year and a half
Jeff tells eg that Kaylie is all about
wallpaper in these days she also redid
rooms of paper from Jeff's personal
glazed collection check out the guest
bedroom in this subtle gray pattern
called wired now we're told the horse
decor in the kitchen is the only animal
inspired print she used but still it
makes sense she's been all about her
horses lately he's sharing several pics
and videos with her horse Neddy and
earlier this week she revealed she was
named the Humane Societies horse woman
of the year
you